[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir el desarrollo
de la copa américa y eurocopa estos son
nuestros titulares italia sufrido pero
se metió en los cuartos de final la
subvención o sea 1 austria en la
prórroga y está entre los 8 mejores a
esa instancia también accedió dinamarca
con una goleada 4 a 0 ante gales
bélgica y portugal protagonizan uno de
los grandes duelos de los octavos de
final uno de los dos favoritos se
despedirá del torneo en sevilla
analizamos este partidazo
se cierra el grupo b de la copa américa
con dos lugares en cuartos por definir
perú y venezuela- disfrutar un mano a
mano es decisivo y ecuador necesita
llevarse algo ante brasil repasamos los
posibles escenarios
como cada día le damos la bienvenida a
nuestra analista sarah castro directora
del diario gas colombia será bienvenida
hola federico un gusto mucho que
analizar así que arranquemos arranquemos
con la eurocopa porque con dos partidos
se abrieron los octavos de final que ya
tiene a dinamarca e italia entre los
ocho mejores en el primer turno
dinamarca goleó 4 a 0 a una apática
galés el casper dolber por duplicado
joaquim miley y martín break away
marcaron para los nórdicos
luego austria llevó a italia está en la
prórroga pero allí la churra se impuso 2
a 1
federico que esa y mateo piscina
marcaron en el primer tiempo extra sea
sacar la xxix de descontó en el segundo
cortando la mejor racha histórica de
italia sin recibir goles con 1.168
minutos ahora dinamarca espera por el
vencedor de países bajos y república
checa e italia guardia aguarda por
bélgica o portugal tras el partido de
roberto mancini se refirió al exigente
exigente encuentro
y mete en gran dificultad berger ellos
te causan muchos problemas porque no te
dejan jugar y nos provocaron muchos
inconvenientes en especial en la segunda
mitad no tanto en los primeros 45
minutos creo que podríamos haber marcado
en la etapa inicial porque generamos
ocasiones pero ellos son un equipo
contra el que es muy difícil jugar a una
jugada es difícil afrontar sala mancini
había avisado que austria es un equipo
que te puede llevar a jugar mal los de
franco fue dicen en un gran partido se
lo podrían haber sonado en el segundo
tiempo pero finalmente prevaleció italia
cuáles fueron las claves de este triunfo
bueno federico hay mucha gente que dice
que las estadísticas muestran todo menos
lo importante y creo que este es el caso
de italia más allá de que llega a su
duodécimo triunfo consecutivo 31
partidos sin perder ayer vimos algo más
importante primero que austria es uno de
los equipos más competitivos que hemos
visto en esta eurocopa y siempre intento
llevar a italia a jugar a su a su lugar
menos menos cómodo en el primer tiempo
logró solucionarlo a través de espinas o
la que se ha hecho un torneo brutal y
todo lo que genera desde esa banda
izquierda puso digamos en dominio italia
tal como lo decía manchin
para la segunda parte creo que el
favoritismo también empieza a pesar en
la toma de decisiones el riesgo a
perderlo todo hace que los jugadores
cometieran errores que no eran claves y
austria aprovechando esas oportunidades
incluso hay una jugada de gol anulada
por el bar arnautovic que delantero
guapo puso problemas a la defensa con
las pocas oportunidades que tuvo pero
luego vimos lo más importante está
italia una reconexión con ese adn de la
valentía y vimos a italia que sabe
sufrir y que se impone con la autoridad
creo que los cambios de mancini fueron
fundamentales entre lan y locatelli
chiesa que anotó un golazo y piscina que
también marcó y nos vimos en una
prórroga llena de valentía orgullo y un
poco de convicción a la idea pero
también apelando a todo eso que ellos
también son un partido muy muy
interesante de ver y creo que bueno
cumplió este estos octavos de final con
que la eurocopa ha tenido muy buen
futuro en el otro partido también vino
vimos a dinamarca con esa versatilidad
de ese juego ofensivo que lo ha
caracterizado en frente a una versión de
gales muy pobre es ahora o se empieza a
convertir dinamarca
a temer para los favoritos la verdad es
que fue muy interesante el de dinamarca
ya habíamos hablado aquí de la vocación
ofensiva le anotó un gol a bélgica que
era complicado él anotó 4 rusia ayer 4
galés pero creo que lo que vimos es un
equipo muy trabajado es un equipo que
juega al juego de posición y que lo
tiene muy bien incorporado los jugadores
lo interpretan con convicción casi y con
confianza luego vimos un entrenador que
leyó muy bien el partido cambió el
sistema durante el partido y las fichas
siguieron funcionando altos niveles
individuales creo que el análisis de la
siguiente ronda dependerá del rival que
en este momento puede ser o países bajos
o república checa pero un equipo muy
interesante y sobre todo siempre
insistiremos que uno de los que más ha
emocionado después de la escena que
tuvieron que vivir con el excel bien en
esta jornada de octavos de final
continúa este domingo con dos partidos
de gran peso en estos momentos se juegan
países bajos y república checa- están
igualando 0 a 0 en budapest
más tarde choca en bélgica portugal nos
quedamos con este duelo de candidatos
que bien podría haberse dado más
adelante en este torneo
será la primera vez que se enfrenten en
la fase final de un gran certamen el
historial es muy parejo con seis
victorias para portugal y cinco para
bélgica los diablos rojos llegaron con
puntaje ideal por primera vez en una
fase de grupos de eurocopa los lusos
sumaron sólo cuatro puntos y avanzaron
como terceros pero llevan cinco partidos
sin perder contra su rival de hoy
escuchamos a los entrenadores de cada
este encuentro bojan ahora todos sabemos
que portugal es un grupo de
individualidades fenomenales pero
también son un equipo ganador ellos
saben trabajar sin el balón por largos
ratos sentirse cómodos con eso y será
una verdadera amenaza en el contraataque
temps lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar espacios el equipo que sepa
defender mejor que no de espacios que
sepa mantener la posición del balón y
crear oportunidades de marcar ese va a
ser el equipo ganador y creo que
portugal hará eso muy bien
a ver la expresión choque de estilos
suele usarse en muchas veces de manera
liviana pero me parece que encaja en
este en este encuentro y a bélgica le
llega portugal quizás en un muy buen
momento en cuanto a funcionamiento y en
recuperación de nombres para el equipo
de martínez si lo de roberto martínez es
muy interesante porque eso hace honor a
un proyecto un proyecto de jugadores que
llegaron a la tercera posición en el
mundial de rusia y que creo que hoy han
ganado esta experiencia siempre se le ha
calificado un equipo frío que necesita
mucha motivación para entrar en partido
pero ya vemos aquí a un lado hasta la
sociedad de debruine lukaku y el
espectáculo que pueden generar esos
jugadores los dos entrenadores hacen una
lectura absolutamente correcta
portugal no ha brillado pero es un
equipo que ha aprovechado muy bien las
transiciones es decir cuando el equipo
rival está atacando y deja espacios
ellos aprovechan mucho con velocidad y
luego esas individualidades seguramente
gane o pierda portugal mañana estaremos
hablando aquí de otro récord de
cristiano ronaldo
pero si es un duelo de estilo es un
partido muy interesante y creo que ya
para esta etapa esperamos ver un bélgica
aún más consolidado paso con puntaje
perfecto pero queremos seguir viendo ese
engranaje sobre todo en el tema ofensivo
esto es juego de posesión roberto
martínez un tipo que lo conoce muy bien
así que partidazo además con seis mil
hinchas mínimo que vinieron de portugal
a acompañar a su selección en sevilla y
para portugal puede ser una oportunidad
de despegue también de fue una primera
fase con dudas si bien lo decía roberto
martínez hay individualidades muy
interesantes el dominio en el mediocampo
va a ser fundamental que se genere un
poco más de juego que no entreguen tanto
la pelota
fernandes antes había hablado de
posesión y creo que ahí va a estar la
clave también del partido es un partido
muy interesante es supremamente
interesante porque también en estas
fases son las decisiones individuales y
los jugadores inteligentes los que
pueden marcar el camino de cómo se
desarrollan los partidos
bien y pasamos ahora a la copa américa
porque esta jornada final del grupo b
pone en juego dos cupos para los cuartos
de final dos cupos para tres equipos
venezuela-perú es el duelo directo a la
blanquirroja de alcanza con un empate y
la vinotinto debe ganar para no depender
de nadie al mismo tiempo ecuador también
está obligado a ganar ante brasil que
llega clasificada y primera latino
contará con damián díaz que contrajo con
19 y la verdemarela descartó al defensor
felipe por lesión su reemplazo es leo
ortiz de el bragantino colombia espera
esta jornada final para saber si será
tercera o cuarta mucho se ha hablado del
estado de los campos de juego en esta
copa y el seleccionador brasileño tite
ha sido uno de los más críticos sus
cuestionamientos le valieron una multa
de conmebol irónico se refirió a este
tema
no voy a decir nada de nuevo si digo
algo me multan o si hablo sobre el mal
estado del campo me multan si critico la
organización del torneo me multan no voy
a decir nada va a pasar de nuevo el
campo del maracaná no va a estar bien lo
cambiaron pero no hay tiempo suficiente
para que esté bien recuerden mis
palabras
para ti te da entender que ni siquiera
el maracaná va a estar listo para la
final y no ha sido el único crítico con
la situación de los campos de juego cómo
afecta a la competencia del hecho de no
tener un buen césped para desarrollar el
fútbol bueno federico no es sorpresivo
que un torneo que decide sucede casi que
una semana antes del inicio e iba a
tener problemas con la infraestructura y
con cómo van a estar a disposición los
campos justamente estaba pensando que es
muy extraño que en el país del fútbol
los campos tengan estas características
sobre todo por el estilo de juego al
piso que se maneja ahí y esto también
nos pone además en contexto de lo que
pasa con los equipos sudamericanos a
nivel mundial no y es que más allá de
tener jugadores talentosos buenos
entrenadores toda la infraestructura que
rodea estos proyectos deportivos es
fundamental lo del maracaná es
preocupante ya la conmebol dijo que lo
está preparando para tenerlo listo para
la final pero sin duda ti te queda más
es un tipo que declara muy bien ha visto
afectado el juego de su equipo por el
estado de estos campos en esta copa
américa te pido brevemente unas líneas
sobre este decisivo venezuela-perú
bueno no hemos visto cuál es la cara
real de perú es un equipo con muy buenos
jugadores que ha empezado a subir el
nivel y luego venezuela en el partido
contra ecuador demostró que si bien ha
tenido todas estas bajas de las que ya
hemos hablado mucho es un equipo que
cuando ataca puede hacer daño vamos a
ver con qué se queda peseiro si con la
seguridad o con apostar un poquito más y
ya gareca que tenga el equipo un poco
más trabajado y más conformado es un
partido interesante de ver y bueno ahí
están las condiciones que se ha dado
venezuela pasaría la heróica realmente
en un torneo absolutamente complicado
para ellos veremos qué resulta de este
importante duelo en diario de copas
repasamos otras novedades vinculadas a
estos dos torneos chile pierde a
guillermo mann y pan para el resto de la
copa américa el defensor sufrió un
desgarro microfibrilar en el recto
anterior de su pierna derecha y quedó
descartado a su vez martín lasarte
espera recuperar a eric pulgar y gary
medel para los cuartos de final
ivan perisic se dio positivo por kobe 19
y no estará para croacia ante españa en
los octavos de final
el extremo cumplirá un aislamiento de 10
días y recién podría volver para una
eventual final su baja para los octavos
de final se suman en el defensor dejando
brent suspendido por acumulación de
amarillas
españa llegó a copenhague para enfrentar
a croacia en los octavos de final de la
eurocopa la roja realizó su último
entrenamiento en las rozas a donde no
regresaría hasta una eventual semifinal
luís enrique podría repetir el equipo
que goleó a eslovaquia
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos
muchísimas gracias ahora por estar
nuevamente con nosotros y a ustedes por
estar del otro lado sigan con más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
i